daniel
it is my pleasure to be speaking to the
stephanie lagrassa of survivor 42. thank
you for chatting today
no problem happy to do it and i'm
honored that you i even qualified for
being close to stephanie lagrosso
i mean well let's get into why you're
stephanie stephanie lagrassa your
shoulder yeah so we said that your
shoulder affected your ability to
participate in challenges your ability
to fishing to go fishing yeah maybe not
so much
do you think your shoulder affected your
game
um i mean obviously everything affects
your game you know this like every
single factor gets put into the
perception of you by your other
castmates and it like gets churned out
in the voting room um so of course it
did i would say
look in terms of like the medical facts
the the shoulder injury was pretty
severe i had to consider surgery when i
got back i decided not to get it but i
went through two months of physical
therapy and then
um
you know i'm thankful i have an open
workers comp claim i probably need to
close that at this point but uh i you
know before any challenge you meet the
doctor and i would always ask the doctor
can i do this challenge and i'd always
keep my fingers crossed if there'd be
you know a puzzle like there's never
just like a puzzle at the end in season
42 i kept thinking there'd be a puzzle
at the end i was devastated because i
for decades have wanted to be on the
show and one of the biggest parts of it
is competing in challenges so it was
actually sad that i never could when the
doctor i mean i could have but i would
have risked long-term physical injury to
my shoulder which i'm just not going to
do the reason i could snorkel but not do
challenges is because you have control
over your range of motion when you're
doing the thing and it's only you and
there's not like other stuff going on
and like a task that you have to perform
and like maybe you're going to get hit
by someone like that's very different
very very different was it smart no
probably not but like you know we can
get into more of the why'd you go
fishing stuff i had plenty to say but
that's like the medical facts those are
the medical facts
okay well then when you were fishing how
did it feel to see your tribe mates on
tv say that they felt like they were
carrying you and really questioning your
decision to go fishing
yeah i didn't watch actually um i
haven't seen it so i will uh
i'll reserve my answer for when i watch
it a few months from now um
you know i think uh i just need to get
to a place where i i watch watch that um
right now there's a lot going on so um i
would say like look i understand it was
probably like they were having a
rational response to it i probably could
have done a better job explaining it
although no one ever really to me this
is like
nothing was vocalized when i was out
there about um any objection to it it
was kind of like kind of a celebratory
thing actually they were kind of like
encouraging me to go to bed
so uh
the uh it was a shock to me upon
returning but look i i went fishing in
park for two reasons the first is like i
just thought i was safe i was wrong i
was wrong about that but i thought i was
safe i had a
conversation with hi on the beach a few
days after the cluster of a tribal
and
i had a convo with him where
we you know i expressed how grateful i
was to be out there playing and i told
him i'm out here i want to like
represent sick kids playing survivor and
we have this like emotional touching
conversation and we hug each other and i
thought after that i'm like i'm totally
safe i don't need to worry i'm like
chanel is going home i'm in the clear i
felt so safe hai is excellent so
excellent player i think he didn't have
great social game for the first seven
days that's why he and lydia were on the
outs but he excellent this excellent
exception so you know i thought i
thought i was safe enough that i could
literally go fishing and then the other
thing
i went i doubled down on the strategy
coming out of the cluster tribal of
daniel needs to re i need to regain
trust i will regain trust by not being a
scheme right chanel she's out scheming
that will play poorly for her you need
to not scheme you need to tell them all
the things you did up until that point
be honest about your dishonesty and then
be totally not skinny going forward in
fact i am so not scheming that i'm out
in the ocean not scheming like you can
see me not scheming out in the ocean and
just bad it was a bad bad call on my
part but like i thought that was the
play i went all in on that play just
don't be a schemer and be honest about
stuff
okay well thank you for giving us more
of the context going into tribal because
on the show as you were walking out of
tribal you say to yourself that was
heartbreaking which is obviously sad to
watch we know that you're a huge fan so
when you were going into tribal council
where did you think all of the votes
were going to fall
um so
i thought that chanel would go home
i thought mike was voting chanel i was
voting chanel um i'm trying to remember
i thought
mike high and me were voting chanel i
thought there was a chance that lydia
would vote for me
um just in case you know chanel played
her shot in the dark and also like lydia
was never gonna not vote for me after
that clustered
um
and chanel i just thought was gonna vote
for me um so i thought i was told again
i had that combo with high and i thought
i was totally safe i really did i
thought i was totally safe so i was
blindsided but erica you've never been
voted out one day you might and i'm
telling you the best way to go out
is a blind side why do you want to roll
a little dinky dice and then have a
thing like who can who wants that i got
the real survivor experience by getting
blindsided
okay that's a great way to put it right
because i think that for the other
tribes we've seen that there have been a
lot of unanimous or near unanimous votes
someone plays the shot in the dark
except when it comes to vati it's always
so complicated with these ties and these
re-votes so what do you think it is
about vati where they're not producing
these unanimous or near unanimous votes
i i don't have an answer to that beyond
it's just a great group of people i mean
look i said in my first
i think one of my first confessionals
that there isn't a dud on the bhati
tribe and i still believe that like i i
think everyone on the bhati tribe is an
excellent survivor player i think um you
know
there were various differences in
strategy though like hai i think is a
very much a strategist i think mike is
very much a social player
chanel is like totally not getting
enough credit um she made one bad
decision
and in reality in 40 out of 42 seasons
of survivor that's not a decision she
would have been confronted with you
cannot prepare for that and in 40 out of
42 seasons of survivor chanel sails
through the first vote and lydia goes
home so like we have all these people
who are very good at the game um i think
it just makes for a fun entertaining tv
and then also like for human beings who
have emotional responses to stuff and
there was something like exciting
emotional things that happen
okay i want to ask about chanel because
you were saying she's not getting enough
credit i know that there's a lot of
chatter online about her vote for mike
last night so i can't talk to chanel
right now so i have you are you able to
sh to shed some light on why chanel
might have voted for mike
yeah i'm i'm very sorry to do this but
like i can't and my reason is
that
when mike's name when the votes were
read i
knew it was over right i knew i was
toast because i was expecting chanel to
go home and like mike gets a vote like
who gets whoever gets a vote who cares
at that point i know i'm toast and i in
that moment and just thinking to myself
this is the end like this journey for
you began decades ago
when you're sick with no hair in a
hospital bed and you're watching people
on tv play this game you love and like
you fell in love with it and you say to
yourself one day i'ma go out there and
do it
and like now it's the end and
take in the last few few
moments that you have with this which is
why when i went and grabbed my torch i i
think i said something to the effect of
like you know soak this in because
there's one time in your life where jeff
is gonna unless you're you unless you're
erica there's one time in your life
jeff's gonna snuff your torch right and
you should really focus on that when
it's happening so like mike gets a vote
whoever gets a vote whatever you'll find
out later for me i was just i was just
soaking it in the best i possibly could
no i think that's a great attitude to
have because i think that yeah
unfortunately not everyone's going to
win so you have to just take advantage
of whatever experience you get and i
think that for you
at least you created this memorable
moment a few tribal councils ago that
infamous
i told them i was interviewing you tell
me that they wanted to hear from you
what were you thinking during that
tribal council where you were starting
to put the attention on chanel and kind
of
put the spotlight on her
um yeah how much time how much time do
we have
remaining um
you're my last interview so hopefully we
can just go a bit long but um
look the
the
the story begins well before that
the story begins like when chanel and i
our
first seven days
we're an alliance we're tight she was my
number one i was all in on chanel
totally all in on chanel which is to her
credit great social player i liked her i
was all in on chanel so much so this is
the example i used so much so that i
shared with her that mike lost his vote
which gives her the power to get rid of
me because she can now go to hai and
lydia and say look let's get rid of
daniel and then she's in between two
pairs of two right so i literally gave
her the power to get rid of me that's
how much i trusted her i was that all in
on chanel and then right before we go to
the immunity challenge that we lost
chanel and i have a one-on-one convo and
we both agree
we will under no circumstances risk our
vote if we go to the summit like we will
not do it so when chanel comes back from
the summit and she tells me i lost my
vote that's the crucial moment everyone
wants to focus on the tribal council and
i understand why it's salacious and i
did a bad job and whatever but where i
really did a bad job was that when she
comes back from the summit she says i
lost my vote what do you do in that
moment you got 600 calories total of
food in you over seven days you know how
it is probably you know how it is more
than me
what do you do then
and that's where i fluffed it i made the
mistake of being loyal to chanel then
like i doubled down on the loyalty i
decided going into the tribal i'm a
stick with chanel she's my number one
i'm all in on her i'll vote lydia
on the re-vote i double down i triple
down i vote lydia again
and then when it comes to the rocks
moment this is what everyone wants to
talk about so i'll give you the red meat
okay
um
i didn't see it as a game of chicken
which is what it was but i didn't see it
that way i saw it i asked erica do you
remember what i asked jeff right before
discussion opened or whatnot i called it
discussion it was actually negotiation
but i thought it was discussion do you
remember what i asked him
no remind me remind me of everybody
watching okay i asked him who would draw
rocks is it just hi and i or is it
chanel mike
hi and me and i asked that because i
wanted to know whose fate was at stake
like whose fate is in my hands and i
found out
mike and chanel my allies their fate is
in my hands right now if we go to rocks
one of my allies might go home and one
out of four chance that like
actually two out of four chance that one
of my allies goes home and their dream
is over so i think to myself like
i need to have their back all right so i
opened the negotiation what i thought
was a discussion
with a terrible opener but my opener was
designed to communicate to mike and
chanel
i have your back don't worry i will not
make you draw rocks you can
have faith in me
and i was thinking the three of us will
together
manipulate the discussion to get high to
flip and have lydia go home
but unfortunately for me i got the worst
case scenario and what like best case
scenario is mike and chanel say
we're with daniel we think lydia should
go home hi you gotta back down like
you'll be on the outs if you don't
medium case scenario is they just join
the discussion and try to manipulate it
subtly without taking a side on the on
the face but really like they're trying
to get rid of lydia worst case scenario
is what happened erica worst case
scenario is
mike said daniel i don't know you go
away i have nothing to do with this i
don't have a vote this is all you and hi
this is your problem chanel says daniel
i don't know you this is like not my
problem you and i have to figure this
out i don't have a vote go away so in
that moment
i felt as if up until then if you look
at every action i ever took up until
then i was totally loyal to chanel and
up until then i was totally loyal to
mike except for when i shared with
chanel about his eye okay and at that
moment i felt like i was just totally
alone totally and utterly alone left out
to dry my allies had abandoned me and i
had a human emotional response to that
that was you know probably not great but
that's kind of where i was coming from
um
and
another thing to know is i would have
gone to rocks if i had known
there wasn't going to be a swap the next
day i was convinced
that there would be a swap we would go
into two tribes of seven because there
would be 14 left after that i was
convinced so i'm like all right
my alliance members have abandoned me
like but
at the very least there will be a swap
tomorrow and like i can figure things
out from there and i was just wrong i
was wrong on every level eric i was
wrong about mike and chanel i was wrong
about there being a swap i was just
wrong
i mean you're just doing the best with
what you know at the time
i've played in the new era too there's
no way we can anticipate that there's no
swap that's unprecedented i guess for me
it was unprecedented for you you didn't
know that we didn't have that
and i want to clarify you said earlier
you hadn't watched it yet did you just
not watch this week's episode or have
you not watched the show at all yet i
watched the first three episodes um
after that you know to be blunt i got
some i got like a death threat it's not
been great i decided i need like
to just get some space it's been very
hard i just proposed a week and a half
ago i actually booked the photographer
for um i didn't think in advance and i
booked the foot i like just wanted to
get married as soon as i had the ring so
i'm like i'm gonna get the ring on this
date and then as soon as i can propose
is this date like i don't want to wait
around i love this woman let's do it
and i didn't look at the calendar and
realized that that date that i booked
the photographer for for was the like
sunday after episode three when it was a
storm so
i like it's been hard on her it's been
hard on me i think basically i love
survivor but i need to give it some
space and like i'll watch it a few
months it's very different to watch your
episode that you're on when it's like a
few months from now and everyone has
forgotten you which i hope they do um i
hope everyone just forgets me and they
go away and like i just watch the
episode in peace eat some taco bell and
then get on with my life but it's very
different to watch it then versus watch
it now when it's the whole shebang
i mean i can totally empathize with you
i think even as you were talking about
that chanel moment at tribal council the
viewers don't realize there's a lot of
layers and complexities to the decision
making it's not just simply you pointing
at lydia and trying sorry pointing at
chanel and trying to throw her under the
bus and yes also empathize with how the
experience of playing the game is very
different than the experience of
watching the show
knowing that you are a super fan and you
got the chance to play the game what's
the biggest takeaway you get from
actually
being able to go out there and
experience everything what's something
you're going to carry with you for for
the rest of your life yeah i think like
look the
the if i sat down in a restaurant they
gave me the survivor menu
of everything on the survivor experience
list you've been through it all you get
the you put your video together you go
through casting you do the pre-game you
do this
like all the fun stuff before you get
out there then you get out there and
you're doing all the stuff then you have
the game and like you last two days
you'll ask one day you'll ask like the
whole time you win congratulations you
won like and then there's the stuff that
comes after and that lasts a lifetime so
like the survivor menu has a lot of
stuff on it
and you
are lucky you will get everything on the
server actually no you're not you didn't
get blindsided like i'm sorry to tell
you i got a survivor experience i got a
survivor experience that you didn't get
all right so like i got something on
that menu that you didn't get you have
to go play again and maybe it'll happen
or you'll sandra diaz twine it or
whatever but like i got
80 of what's on that menu even though i
went out on day 11 right that's what i
take away is like
i i'm fine with this experience i i got
whether i lasted to two days 29 days or
like anything in between i get the vast
bulk of what's on the survivor menu and
i'm very pleased with that
well daniel rapid fire question one name
who are you rooting for to win survivor
42
um do you want me to answer this from
the perspective of when i had just left
the game or right now
whatever you want
okay um when i had just left the game i
would have been
rooting for
probably chanel
um for sure i would have been rooting
for chanel when i just left the game
i knew that the two of us had to face
off against each other i had no ill will
towards her
um
and right now i'm i think i'm i'm
rooting for
um
let's see right now
i'm rooting for
mike
amazing all right well daniel you
created some fun moments to watch on tv
and i want to say congratulations for
living your survivor dream and for your
wedding and all of the things to come
and i want to say thank you so much for
chatting and wish you all the best thank
you thank you was a delight and
congratulations again on achieving the
victory
you